today the mattwell show the creator of
the Dilbert comic strip has been exiled
and canceled from polite Society for
comments he made about a new poll which
shows that a large percentage of
Americans don't think it's okay to be
white but I think the poll itself is far
more important and far more troubling
than whatever comments anyone made about
it we'll talk about that today also
zielinski scolds Americans who don't
want to continue shuffling billions of
dollars into his government's Pockets
Rhonda Santos lays out exactly how he
would drain the swamp as president Woody
Harrelson speaks the truth about covet
and big Pharma on SNL but is it too
little too late and John fetterman's
wife goes on a journey of self-discovery
while her husband suffers in the
hospital is she the rightful winner of
the worst wife in America Title discuss
all that and much more today on Matt
Walsh
foreign
[Music]
as you may have heard the U.S blew
through the 31.4 trillion dollar debt
ceiling in December and still the White
House refuses to reduce spending uh to
dig our country out of this mountain of
debt every single taxpayer in America
would have to write a check for 247
thousand dollars so just you know if you
got that laying around in the bank
that's the good news our economy is in
trouble in other words it's time to
start thinking about your Investments
and your future you need to consider
diversifying into gold with Birch gold
Birch gold is a leading dealer of
physical precious metals in the U.S
their Dynamic team of former wealth
managers financial advisors and
commodity Brokers can help you diversify
your portfolio into gold and silver
they'll even show you how to convert
your IRA or 401K into an IRA in Precious
Metals Tex Walsh to 98 98 98 to claim
your free info kit on gold and then talk
to one of their precious metal
Specialists with your retirement at
stake you want to be confident in the
financial services companies that you
work with including uh who you choose
for purchasing physical precious metals
text Walls to 98 98 98 and protect your
savings with gold today
Scott Adams The Man Behind the Dilbert
cartoon had a successful career as of
this past Friday emphasis on had his
comic strip was published in hundreds of
newspapers uh thousands I think actually
emphasis on was today his career is
effectively over in the span of two or
three days he was dropped by every major
newspaper and most of the non-major ones
too and then finally last night dumped
by Andrews McNeil Universal which is
Dilbert's longtime distributor they also
have severed ties with Scott Adams it's
one of the fastest and most thorough
cancellations we've yet seen rivaled
perhaps only by the short span of time
when Kanye West lost well over half his
net worth I think even more than that
for Scott Adams his cancellation was
prompted by comments that he made on his
YouTube live stream and this was a live
stream that he that was published I
think on Wednesday and then and then for
whatever reason took a couple days
before people noticed it and then they
noticed it and he was canceled on this
live stream he advised that white people
should quote get the hell away from
black people he warned that quote
there's no fixing this and that quote
White Citizens can no longer help quote
black citizens
now if you're curious about the this
he's referring to what exactly we can't
fix according to Adams the daily wire
covers that in its report quote
in a real coffee with Scott Adams video
posted on Wednesday Adams discussed a
Rasmussen poll that nearly half of black
Americans were unable to agree with the
phrase it's okay to be white Adam's
video in which he suggested that poll
results indicate that blacks are a quote
hate group went viral Adams in the video
joked that he's been identifying as
black for some time but must have
accidentally joined a hate group based
on a recent Rasmussen poll the poll
which surveyed a thousand people showed
that 53 of black people agreed with the
statement it's okay to be white leaving
47 unable to say they agree
now
call me a contrarian I've been told I've
been called worse than that and but it
would seem to me that the headline of
this story
is not what the Dilbert guy said on some
YouTube video given that he's just one
guy expressing a Viewpoint that is
clearly rejected by every powerful
institution in our society
but rather the story is the survey which
would seem to indicate widespread racial
animosity in the American population
so when I heard this that's the first
thing that I noticed I said well wait a
second what about this survey
the mainstream media would have us
believe that the roundly rejected and
condemned opinion of one man is a
greater concern and a much more urgent
National crisis than the racist
viewpoints revealed in the poll that he
was reacting to
but I would argue that we should
probably take some time I mean once
everyone has had their turn jumping on
the Scott Adams dog pile and I think by
now everyone has had their turn because
that's where the cancellation goes like
one one guy says something that lots of
people don't like and then uh and then
everyone jumps on it it's like even
after three or four days and 10 million
people have already jumped on the
Dogpile and said I too disagree with
this statement I think it's horrible
still you got someone else has to come
along and say I also disagree
well now that we've done that
um
can we talk about this survey and what
it purports to reveal
in fact I think the time to talk about
is probably right now so let's do that
looking at that Rasmussen poll again
it asks respondents whether they agree
or disagree with the statement it's okay
to be white
now among black respondents a slim
majority which is 53 percent
strongly or somewhat agree that it's
okay to be white but 26 strongly or
somewhat disagree while 21 aren't sure
that leaves as we said 47 percent who
cannot definitively say that it's okay
to be white
which is to say they cannot agree that
white people should exist
because that would be the implication if
it's not okay to be a member of a
certain race then what you're saying is
that it's not okay that that race exists
in fact even among white people only 67
percent would strongly agree that it's
okay for them to be the race that they
are
another 14 somewhat agree is it okay to
be what you are maybe sort of
leaving 20 who cannot say that they
agree at all that it's okay for them to
be the race that they are
now if these numbers are accurate they
reveal a truly dangerous level of hatred
and animosity against whites and and
even shared by a large percentage of
whites against themselves as well
now you could argue that this poll only
surveyed a thousand people doesn't
represent a true and accurate
cross-section of the American people
therefore you could also argue that
Rasmussen is a conservative firm I've
heard this on the left as well as it
conserves a right-wing firm and so they
conducted the survey in a way that would
skew the results in their ideological
favor
now on that second point if you're right
that they were skewing the results to
get you know to get the results that
they favor it only makes the results
more concerning after all Rasmussen
reported these results triumphantly as
an indication that most Americans reject
woke racial indoctrination
so if they were trying to prove anything
with the survey they were trying to
prove that anti-white racism is not
widespread
as that would show that normal Americans
reject wokism their own headline about
the poll results that's what it declares
Americans reject uh woke racial
indoctrination
and yet even in that effort they
inadvertently showed the opposite
the sample size is small though you know
that I would Grant
but the whole science of polling is to
ascertain General sentiments by
quantifying the opinions of a small
group now your faith in that science or
pseudoscience may be rather limited I
mean I know that mine is
but I can't help but notice that many
people who regularly tout poll results
are when it comes to this particular
poll eager to declare that the results
must be wrong
I'm willing to listen to an argument
that the results are wrong because I'm
naturally skeptical of all polls but
that would require contrary evidence
right evidence that anti-white beliefs
are not widespread
but I haven't seen any Skeptics Skeptics
provide such evidence so you could say
that well no there's no way that that
many uh black people feel that way about
white people or even that that many
white people feel that way about them
there's no way that's true okay well why
do you think it's not true
like what based on what you're assuming
that it's not true based on what do you
assume that
indeed the evidence seems to go the
other way
what makes the results especially
disturbing is that they are not a shock
but they don't seem to be an aberration
instead they can port with much of what
we see in society including from other
polls just recently The Washington Post
conducted their own survey finding that
70 percent of black Americans believe
that half of all whites
are white supremacists
over 49 of um
or rather over 40 percent of black
respondents claim that all or most
whites are white supremacists in fact
across two different polls the number of
black Americans who believe that it's
not okay to be white and that most white
people are white supremacists is almost
identical they're off by a few
percentage points that's either an
incredible coincidence or an indication
of something very troubling
we don't need polls you could see the
anti-white sentiment everywhere in plain
sight take this Infamous video which
happened to go viral this week as well
along with the Scott Adams stuff where
anti-white racism is casually paraded
right in front of our faces watch this
why are white people's Superior at
[Laughter]
the white people's Superior Superior
they're real good at violence violence
genocide it's like stealing people's
lives just because they feel like it if
you are white and you know this is
happening and you say nothing then
you're a killer too what exactly are
white people prepare you're at
insecurity pretending fear being fearful
of nothing being ignorant blame letting
their egos control their every move
Superior at being
what exactly are white people Superior
at oppression gaslighting lack of
empathy intellectualizing oppression did
I say oppression what exactly are white
people Superior at taking what's not
there taking taking our ideas copycat
gentrification appropriating things that
do not belong to them taking over other
people's cultures and making you believe
that they invented it maybe they're
thinking as repurposing it's like
recycle and repurpose as my grandma was
saying then white folk they'll take it
if you don't copyright it they are very
good at destruction of land destruction
of people destruction of humanness
public hearing really difficult whether
conservative like white people are
really good at upholding white supremacy
how about claiming that you know they
are actually a whole separate race when
actually white DNA comes from the black
female so what exactly are white people
Superior honey lion stealing and
cheating manipulation withholding
information lying telling lies
hmm
uh now the point is not just what the
bigots in the video said uh it's that
the video exists in the first place you
would never see a mainstream Outlet or
even a non-mainstream outlet uh produce
and publish a video with the races
swapped and that is so obvious that it's
become a truism the racial double
standard is so apparent that even people
who oppose the double standard get sick
of hearing others point it out because
you know like we know it
but the global standard is so clear to
everyone is yet more evidence to support
the results of the poll
the reaction to Scott Adams proves it
too now we all know that if Scott had
darker skin and had instead been
advising blacks to get the hell away
from whites
he would not have lost a single
newspaper if anything he would have
gained a few more
we know for a this is not this is not me
assuming this we know for a fact that
it's true because race Hustlers on the
other side regularly declare that black
people are not safe around white people
and this is something that's said all
the time despite the fact that there is
zero evidence to support that
but this is something that's always said
and and none of the people who say that
ever suffer the slightest consequence
for saying so
why well because
the most powerful forces in our society
have been working for years to get
exactly the results that we see in that
Rasmussen Bowl
that's perhaps the best evidence that
the poll Is tragically accurate because
it simply reveals the racial animosity
and anti-white hostility that our
culture has been dead set on instilling
in black and white people alike
this doesn't emerge from a vacuum kids
today are raised in schools and they
consume media and they watch films and
shows that all carry the explicit
message that white people are history's
great villains that white people are
inherently racist that whiteness is a
Scourge a disease
in fact a psychoanalyst named Donald
Moss published a paper a couple years
ago that argued explicitly that
here's the first line of the abstract in
this paper
whiteness is a condition one first
acquires and then one has a malignant
parasitic-like condition to which white
people have a particular susceptibility
the last line laments that despite their
best efforts they've yet to come up with
quote a permanent cure for whiteness
those are the exact words permanent cure
if that sounds genocidal it's because it
is
just like the statement it's not okay to
be white reveals genocidal hatred as
there is only one cure for a race that's
that it's not okay to be right if it's
not okay to be a member of a certain
race well how do you cure that what do
you do about that
this is what's brewing
one racial group has been tagged as the
enemy the cancer the cause of all our
social ills
far from the first time in history that
a racial group has been scapegoated in
this way and so we know from history
where it leads
and I think perhaps this
is what we should really be talking
about
now let's get to our five headlines
let's talk about as we already have
about cancel culture on social media
sites and what you can do about the left
wants to silence and boycott any voices
they don't agree with social media is
supposed to be an open platform I don't
need their content moderators acting
like the op-ed section of the New York
Times but that's so often how it works
and that's why I use expressvpn if
you've ever wondered how free to access
sites make all their money if by
tracking your searches or video history
and everything you click on and then
selling your valuable data when I use
expressvpn my online presence is
anonymized making it difficult for
anyone to track my online activity and
to try to shut me down it couldn't be
easier to set up you just tap one button
on your phone or computer and you're
protected it's as simple as that
expressvpn works on all your devices
your phone your tablet your computer
wherever you are in the world expressvpn
can and will protect you
um I Won't Back Down it's time to say no
to censorship you should do the same by
visiting expressvpn.com wall should get
three extra months free that's exp
rssvpn.com Welsh Express bn.com Walsh to
learn more
if you're watching the video podcast
you've perhaps already noticed that
things look more harmonious than they
have in recent weeks the energy is just
uh the energy is right as the kids would
say the vibe the vibe has been restored
to the Matt wall show and that's because
I am wearing my beloved flannel on a
Monday even though it's not flannel
Friday now every day is flannel day once
again the great flannel Wars have come
to their conclusion and the I'm proud to
be excited to announce the pro flannel
faction has won out in this epic
struggle uh and I tried look I tried for
a few months to look professional on
this show with the sports coat and all
that kind of stuff and we're done with
that now because those days are over I'm
not that's not who I I'm not
professional I'm not a professional
person
this is I am a flannel wearing dad
all the way
only thing I'm missing is the white New
Balance sneakers I haven't quite
transitioned to that yet eventually I
will
so I am so I've always been that's who I
was when I was born as we know from the
sweet baby gang logo
can't we can't you can't try to take
that away from me
and so we're back ladies and gentlemen
um
well that's the good news but we go over
to some sad news today uh there's also
uh it's a it's a great day it's a great
day of Celebration because it's uh
flannel you know the flannel has been
restored also a sad day with some very
pitiful news that uh the feds they had
planned a special uh occasion over the
weekend special a special day over the
weekend and nobody came you know it's
kind of the equivalent of having a
birthday party at a Chuck E cheese for a
child and none of his classmates that
you invited show up that's basically
what happened to the feds uh to the FBI
and I I feel very bad for them
it was supposed to be called the day of
hate right so last week late last week
we started hearing about am I say we
started hearing I mean it's this started
popping up on social media and the media
started talking about this thing called
the national day of hate where an
alleged quote unquote far-right groups
were going to March or do something it
was never quite clear what they were
going to do but there was going to be
some widespread national day where lots
of far-right groups are going to be out
in the streets
um showing their hatred for minorities
especially Jewish people but but not
just them this is going to be it's a day
of hate for just like expressing your
hatred
um and it was supposedly being organized
by far-right groups and the neo-nazis
organizing and that's what they said
except that of course any
thinking person could smell the psyop
from a thousand miles away like it's
it's it's not even subtle at this point
yet the media was running with this
um
even though you know I am I'm told a
member of the far right
and uh I'm I've even been told many
times that I'm a Nazi so I don't that's
not how I see myself I didn't I never
met but that's what people tell me
and yet
I never heard about this day of hate all
right I had here I had to hear about it
from the media
because nobody on the right was talking
about it or knew about it
because it was invented by the media and
probably by the feds this story from uh
from the Boston ABC affiliate is
representative this is what they were
pushing
white supremacist groups are trying to
organize a national day of hate to
coincide with the Jewish sabbath this
weekend according to the Anti-Defamation
League this particular effort originated
with a small Neo-Nazi group based in
Eastern Iowa the aadl said while ADL is
not aware of any specific threats we
know that these groups are hoping for
increased anti-semitic flyer
distributions protests and graffiti in
Massachusetts several police departments
said they were aware of the reports but
had no information about anything
planned for the area right now there's
no specific threats that are known we
don't have intelligence that leads us to
believe there's any particular targets
uh but they say they're being vigilant
and they're aware and so there's a lot
of reports like this that the far right
they're gonna have a day of hate nobody
knows who's doing it or what it's going
to be but it's it's happening
then the big day of hate came and uh it
was you know and it was trending on
Twitter and all that
um but then the day comes and nobody
shows up nothing happens because it
never exists in the first place
but how's the media gonna spin that well
they're gonna say well this only proves
that uh that we scared the anti-hate
Brigade away they were going to show up
but we put a stop to it so here's the
Times of Israel this is what they said
no major anti-semitic incidents were
immediately reported in the United
States on Saturday despite widespread
alert over a national day of hate that
had been planned by white supremacists
and Neo-Nazi groups instead of issue if
officials issued statements of
solidarity and demonstrations of unity
which were held in Washington DC and
elsewhere while Jewish Community has
defied the threats by sticking to their
normal uh Shabbat activities law
enforcement and Jewish groups had urged
vigilance ahead of Saturday after the
white supremacists called for followers
to distribute anti-semitic messaging
with Banner stickers flyers and graffiti
um a statement that's attributed to the
hate groups although we're still not
told who the hate groups are but this is
a statement attributed to them take a
stand and expose the international click
of parasitic Vermin that infest our
nation make your voices heard loud and
clear that the one true enemy of the
American people is the Jew
this is what we're told a statement
attributed to the hate groups although
they don't tell us who the hate groups
are
then the day comes and nothing happens
um
you know there's a lot of reasons why
you know we could know going into this
this is basically an invention of the
media now when the media invents
something sometimes there's a there's a
shred of truth to it sometimes there
isn't
so is it possible that someone somewhere
posted something on some obscure chat
room or or message board and then that's
what they're basing this on that's
possible
would that justify uh you know the the
extrapolation that there's some sort of
national uh Incident That's about to
occur of course not
better luck next time feds
okay at a press conference a couple days
ago president zielinski of Ukraine was
asked about Americans who don't want to
keep shipping money to uh to his country
there are some Americans if you can
believe it that after a year of this
some Americans
because they're all Stooges of Putin
um of which apparently I am a stooge of
Putin because I agree with them that no
we don't want to continue shipping money
and weapons or anything else to Ukraine
I don't think we ever should have
started
zolansky has
some thoughts about those Americans like
myself and probably like you this is
what he says
what would your message be on the
anniversary to those Americans thank you
I would like to thank the American
people
I would like to thank all of the
American people that are supporting
Ukraine the Congress the president the
TV
channels the journalists
and everyone that has been supporting us
and that percentage of Americans as
you've mentioned is increasing
I can tell them only one thing
if they do not change their opinion
if they do not understand us if they do
not support Ukraine they will lose NATO
they will lose
um The Cloud of the United States they
will lose the leadership position that
they already joining the world uh that
they are joined for a very fair reason
and they will lose the support of the
country with 40 millions of population
with millions of children our American
children's any different than ours
don't Americans enjoy this the same
things as we do I don't think we're that
different
do we enjoy the same things as you do I
mean maybe
we might have similar hobbies to lots of
people all over the globe we're supposed
to be shipping them all money because of
that
I mean we do ship almost all the money
but is that a good enough reason
this is really this this is everything
you need to know from uh inadvertently
he has told told you everything you need
to know zielinski has
because remember what he was asked he
just asked what about Americans don't
want to they don't want to support
Ukraine anymore they don't want to keep
sending money and all the rest of it
if there was an argument to be made
even a even a uh
unlikely argument but if they were
implausible though it may be if there
was an argument to be made that doing
this
sending the money to Ukraine is in the
best National Security interests of
America that doing it would actually
benefit the American people in a direct
way that you need to do it because if
you don't do it then America will be at
risk maybe because Putin will you know
he'll take over Ukraine then he'll keep
marching he'll take over all of Europe
and then launch it you know
if there was any argument to be made for
that
I wouldn't buy it but if there was then
he then that would have been the time to
make it he doesn't even pretend you
notice that he's not even pretending
that it's in the direct personal
interest of the American people to
support Ukraine he's not even pretending
that it will make us safer to support
Ukraine
instead he says well we like a lot of
the same things we all we all love to
you know walks on the the beach we like
to go for we all love to walk through uh
Meadows on a lazy Saturday afternoon you
know uh you know he gives us that and
then he also says um
that will lose the clout we'll use our
we'll lose our national clout
so
so that that's what we have to spend
billions of dollars on is for for clout
how do you measure the clout of the
globe exactly and why should I care why
should I care if America has clout
especially if this is how you get it
so the way that we get clout Nation
internationally is by paying for it by
buying it
that's all he's got
like I I can't conceive how could any
how could any anybody with a brain at
this point still support sending money
to Ukraine you just heard president he
gave his best sales pitch
and he's not even pretending that it's
going to make us safer that it's best
for our own well-being it's all about
him his real argument is well you should
give us money because we really want it
and I love the threat also that he says
that if we don't we'll lose the support
of the Ukraine Ukrainian people so when
did we ever have your support what do
you mean we'll Lose Yourself what have
you ever done for us zelenski what has
Ukraine ever done for the United States
one thing is they've done one thing
okay because I can name billions of
things we've done for Ukraine what have
they ever done for us
all of these countries that we're
constantly shipping money to it what are
they doing for us what are they doing to
show their support for us nothing
you'll lose the support of Ukraine
number one don't care number two we
never had it
this is a one-way relationship it always
is
all right Rhonda Sanders was interviewed
by Mark Levin
um
over the weekend and I want you to
listen to
you know very often interviews with
politicians are not very interesting but
there was one part that I want you to
hear because this is uh this is
important
I think they wanted to exercise power
over other people so if you look at like
all these entrenched bureaucrats CDC NIH
FD they need to be cleaned out because
they totally failed and they're not
advocating for the best interests of the
people of this country it's been a total
disaster yeah it's hard to remove them
you know the Civil Service rules and
then the union rules and all the rest
and well there was one there was a
proposal uh that I think a lot of us
wanted to see under the prior
Administration to to do a schedule F so
anybody that has any policy role is
classified as a schedule F and they can
be removed by the president the the left
would litigate that but I honestly think
we would win on that in the Supreme
Court and I also think it's one thing to
have some type of job rules for the the
bowels of the bureaucracy like your
supervisor what they can do president
United States has Article 2 power who
controls the the executive branch is it
the elected president or is it some
bureaucrat in the bowels of the
bureaucracy that can't be fired and so I
think push needs to come to shove on
this but whoever gets a majority of the
Electoral College is has the right to
impose their agenda through the
executive branch right and what they did
with President Trump was basically try
to nullify the election through not only
bureaucratic intransigence but
malfeasance with the collusion hoax and
some of those things and so
reconstitutionalizing government starts
with reconstitutionalizing the executive
branch under article 2. okay so uh a lot
of that might sound kind of wonky but it
is uh it is important and listen if you
want to know
why I would take the Sanders over Trump
in a primary
of course I would support either one in
general if you want to know why I would
take the Santa over Trump of the primary
it really there are other reasons that
we've talked about but really this is
the only reason you need
um it is the desire to actually clean
out all of these bureaucrats
all of these entrenched bureaucrats to
clean them out of the system right you
need like uh it's it's like cleaning out
your you need some it's like so how do
you get some Drano to clear all this
gunk out of the out of the pipe stream
and that's what he wants to do not only
the desire to do it but the knowledge of
how to do it
and exp this is what he's done in the
Florida state government he's done
exactly this now it's harder to do on a
national level but we know that he knows
how to do it because he's done it
and um and also from giving explanations
like that the desire and willingness and
follow through to actually use the
powers of the executive branch knowing
how to use those powers and being
interested in using them to get rid of
many of these corrupt uh swamp things
Trump listen Trump never did that he he
he just never did he was elected to
drain the swamp he never did anything to
actually drain it or very little I
should say very little was done and
whatever he did do was was was was
undone within about 12 hours of him
leaving office
so
um
that's what you get from descendants I
mean can you imagine to be honest can
you imagine Trump
calmly explaining
as DeSantis just did how we would
actually get rid of these people
have you ever heard him
then we know we get the you know we
don't get the platitudes and we get the
the bumper sticker slogans we get the
rally speeches and all that and the
talking points and of course you get
that from any politicians and that stuff
is important too
but what about sitting down and saying
listen this is how I'm going to go about
doing this
and being able to explain it
um
you don't get that from Trump very often
you do get it from DeSantis
all right
I guess we'll move to
this uh Woody Harrelson and SNL are
getting some props this week for
really this moment from Harrelson's
monologue while he was hosting the show
on Saturday here it is
okay so the movie goes like this the
biggest drug cartels in the world get
together and buy up all the media and
all the politicians and force all the
people in the world stay locked in their
homes and people can only come out if
they take the cartels drugs and keep
taking them over and over
I threw the script away I mean who is
going to believe that crazy idea okay
it's a good a good moment on the in if
you watch the rest of the clip there's a
few more seconds there but uh you really
need the rest of it because then you
you'll hear the reaction from the crowd
which is mostly it's a little bit of
awkward laughter and then silence
because they are thinking like we're not
supposed to hear this kind of this is
not what we're supposed to hear on SNL
okay and this is from a Hollywood
celebrity he's not supposed to be saying
stuff like this and they don't know how
to react to it
um
but Woody Harrelson's getting a lot of
credit for that for saying this and and
again I'm glad that he's at it
I'm glad that he said it in the Forum
where he said it it's important
but I also have to say that I just
I can't give anyone credit
for being this late to the party now
maybe I'm wrong I I haven't tracked
Woody Harrelson and his
viewpoints very closely or at all
so maybe he came out back in you know
April of 2020 or may of 2020 or even
sometime in 2021
and said this and talked about the you
know refer to the pharmaceutical
companies as a drug cartel they were
forced me you know maybe maybe he was
saying this all along
um I don't remember ever hearing him say
that
so if he did then then I'll give him
credit for that
but if he didn't
and this has got another example of
somebody years later saying what many of
us have been saying
for years up until now
and even Sno
you know I don't know if he got
clearance for that line before he went
up there maybe he was going off script a
little bit I don't know
surprise me if they if they knew the
writers knew that he was going to say
that if that was you know written on a
teleprompter and it was already known
because SNL has also in the last few
months
you know they've done a few bids a few
skits where they're kind of making
similar sorts of points
foreign
but it is so late
and it's just
yeah if you're right if you're if you
say something that is correct now when
it's easy and popular to say it
then you're still correct I'm not gonna
act like it's not correct they'll say
well good that's true I'll agree with it
but that's exactly the point it's once
it's easy and popular to say and there's
no real risk in saying it that I then
the credit for saying it is out the
window
and there are so many examples it's not
just with covet
but you've got a lot of these kind of um
I I know I guess we'd call them old
school I even has that called them old
school liberals because they're only old
school liberals in comparison to the
leftists of you know of the the blue
hair Tick Tock leftist so old school in
that sense there are plenty examples of
these old school quote-unquote liberals
you know making points like this I mean
Bill Maher is another one
whether it's on this on some of the
gender stuff the same thing you get a
little bit of sanity
and conservatives are very excited by
that they want to embrace these people
but it's like yeah I mean you're saying
these you can say this now
okay and I'm not going to hold it
against it I'm not this is not even like
if somebody was wrong about covid two
and a half three years ago
but has long since corrected themselves
you know that's one thing
but to wait this long
to make these kinds of points and
observations
now this is
you risk nothing at this point
speaking of late to the party the New
York Times also had this report new
intelligence has prompted the energy
Department to conclude that an
accidental accidental laboratory league
in China most likely caused the
coronavirus pandemic though U.S by
agencies remain divided over the origins
of virus American officials said on
Sunday the conclusion was a change from
the Department's earlier position that
it was undecided on how the virus
emerged some officials briefed on the
intelligence said it was relatively weak
and that the energy Department's
conclusions was made with low confidence
suggesting that it's a level of
certainty was not high while the
department shared the information with
other agencies none of them changed
their conclusions officials said
officials would not disclose what the
intelligence was but many of the energy
Department's insights come from its
network of National Laboratories some of
which conduct biological research rather
than more traditional forms of
intelligence like spy networks or
Communications intercepts intelligence
officials believe the scrutiny of the
pandemic's beginnings could be important
to improving Global Response to Future
Health crises though the caution that
finding an answer about the source of
the virus maybe difficult or even
possible given Chinese opposition to
further research
another one very late to the party now
yeah they they've they have uh
couched this
clarify they've made very sure and all
the media reports about this they've
made very short to include that well
it's a low level of confidence yeah the
energy department is saying this but we
don't we still don't know exactly
no we know
and this is another one that we knew
essentially from the beginning
it's very clear from the beginning
um
there was at least enough evidence at
the very beginning
like just starting with the fact that oh
this virus originated in Wuhan and there
happens to be this Wuhan lab where
they're in the business of making these
crazy viruses and so it's of all the
places where a virus could emerge the
fact that it emerges right there is
not proof in and of itself coincidences
do happen
but very strong indication that there is
a relationship there
and as more and more information came
out it was uh you know there was enough
reason from the very beginning to
strongly suspect that this came from a
lab
and then
shortly thereafter there was enough
reason to be quite short of it as as
more and more evidence came out
but here we are three years later and
they're saying well yeah it looks like
that could be the case
even if we even if we buy the low level
of confidence thing again it's not low
overcome it's a high level of confidence
maybe if you buy that
well the point is that now you've got
the byte Administration saying
that this is a a very plausible
explanation at the very least
when two or three years ago
they were not only saying the
explanation was implausible they're
actually saying that it's bigoted to
even talk about it
to Simply discuss the possibility that
it might have come from a lab in China
is bigoted and racist they said
this is a yet another example of where
we're not going to give any credit to
anyone whether it's the New York Times
certainly at the Biden Administration
saying three years later yeah maybe
maybe you're right about that
because they won't even they won't even
dignify it dignify Us by by phrasing it
that way
they won't even say well maybe you were
right
it said they're going to pretend that
all the people that were making this
point for years and that they shouted
down they're pretend that we never
existed we never said any of that
here's how the hill by the way the
website the hill is translating all this
this is how they're reporting on it
Republicans are seizing on a new energy
Department conclusion pointing to a lab
leak as causing the kova 19 outbreak to
call for Swift action against the
Chinese government
The Wall Street Journal New York Times
reported Sunday that the energy
Department had determined with low
confidence that the virus was leaked
from a lab though it's unclear what new
intelligence that was based on
so as always the story for you know you
start with the story which is the actual
story that the virus came from a lab we
always knew that
um
but then very quickly the story for the
media becomes not the story itself but
the way people on the right are reacting
to the story
Republicans seize on the information
well no we're not seizing on we've we've
been seizing on it from the very
beginning
if by seizing you mean like pointing to
it and saying hey look at this fact
everyone
in the comment section
this is uh some more big news New York
Times has this
I'm just going to read from it
warm moist air and colder dry air
collided on Wednesday to create the
conditions necessary for Hail damaging
winds and tornadoes across the Southern
Plains and into Southeast and it was the
job of an elite meteorology group called
The Storm Prediction Center to give
people advanced notice
Elizabeth Lightman who has worked at the
Norman Oklahoma center since 2010 it
would be the day she would issue her
first thunderstorm watch she would also
become the first woman ever to do so in
the 70-year history of the center and
its previous iterations according to the
center officials
Ms Lightman is one of only two women
among the 22 full-time forecasters at
the Storm Prediction Center as far as I
know there's been five of us miss
Lightman said referring to female
forecasters who've worked there before
never none of her predecessors though
reached the role of lead forecaster on
Wednesday her first day training to
become a lead forecaster she did all the
intricate work while someone supervised
supervised her every move and then she
made the uh the the she issued the storm
watch
so in summary if you're a little
confused
um a woman
maybe you're confused because you're
wondering where the story actually isn't
but it that's the story a woman issued a
thunderstorm watch for the first time in
history
pretty big stuff
and this is what we're down to now these
are the um these are the glass ceilings
that we're left with right they're not
even glass they're a glass coffee tables
or something they're not even ceilings
this is how desperate they are to
continue pretending that women are
overcoming a sexist patriarchal society
this is what this is how this is how um
specific things have to get
first woman at the center in Oklahoma to
issue a thunderstorm watch
it's next week they're going to be
writing an article about the first woman
to like uh declare that the store is
closing over the intercom on a Tuesday
night at the Walmart in Fort Lauderdale
and uh first woman to do that that's how
specific they need to get
how about the first woman to
walk down the street in green pants
while yodeling in Latin first woman to
do that another glass ceiling broken
very inspiring story for all of us
let's get to the comment section
foreign
[Music]
says I judge harshly people who defend
criminals actions based on mental
illness and or past trauma for every
murder that has fetal alcohol syndrome
there are at least tens of thousands if
not millions of others who have fetal
alcohol syndrome and don't kill is it's
not that mentally ill people commit
crimes that criminals often have mental
illness and there's a huge difference
mentally ill does not equal morally
corrupt
well you're right and this is even more
so the case when you consider the fact
that uh according to psychologists and
psychiatrists these days like everybody
has a mental illness you know um there's
a mental illness for everybody
um and you know you either have been
diagnosed with them with a mental
illness or you haven't been diagnosed
yet because you haven't gone to seek a
diagnosis but anyone who wants one can
get one that's the you know it's the
it's like the the Oprah giving out cards
like you get a mental illness you get a
mental so everyone gets one so if we
start
um excusing uh bad behavior and
especially violent crime on the basis of
mental illness then you very rapidly end
up in a society where
everybody is excused you know you can't
condemn anything because we all have
mental illnesses to fall back on
that's why I'm always I I'm just I'm
very skeptical of
using mental illness as an excuse at all
the the insanity defense
um
very skeptical I've always been very
skeptical of that because the only thing
I need to know
right
you did something terrible uh you heard
somebody and killed someone
I need to know I need to I need to know
two things
did you know that what you were doing
was wrong
and um did you do it on purpose
now if the answer is no to both of those
things you didn't know it was wrong and
or you didn't you didn't do it on
purpose
if you killed someone you still have to
face consequences for that they're still
going to be a very harsh punishment even
if you didn't do it on purpose even if
you didn't know what you were doing
but for the vast majority of murderers
the answer is going to be yes to both of
those things
okay no matter what they went through as
a child as a child no matter what their
childhood trauma was uh they were abused
whatever fetal alcohol syndrome they've
been diagnosed with 50 different mental
illnesses all that stuff could be the
case drug addicts everything else
but
in almost every case
you know where a crime was committed on
purpose they they knew that what they
were doing was wrong
and you know that too because there's
almost always an attempt to hide the
crime or to you know
um to get away with it and somehow
somehow even if the attempt is is Clumsy
and and incompetent they're still the
attempt
let's see
Addie says thank you Matt for speaking
about the real issues of someone who is
lactose intolerant literally break out
in hives and get sick every time I have
a I have dairy I definitely agree that
almond soy coconut Etc milk is in fact
not milk almond juice as I like to call
it is the biggest liar of them all it's
just nasty tan flavored water that
separates into half liquid half solid if
it's not violently shaken every two
seconds so speak your truth it needs to
be said spg4l
well it's good to know that there are
some in the lactose intolerant community
that understand this this lie and this
Veil that's being pulled over their eyes
look I can't imagine actually being
lactose intolerant to me that that that
is uh
that is a that would be a an unthinkable
curse
um because 98 of the stuff that I eat is
you know is dairy or has dairy in it
just starting with the fact that
everything should have cheese on it I
don't care what it is I don't care if
it's a bowl of fruit loops like
everything tastes better with cheese so
maybe not Fruit Loops but most things
um so that would be an incredible curse
but if it if you are cursed that way
then I think that's your cross that
you're bearing don't lie to yourself by
pretending that you can still partake in
the miracle of dairy when you can't so I
commend you for your uh courage in that
regard
um
and finally count snackula says despite
the fact I'm conservative I'm not in
favor of the death penalty our Lord has
made his will clear we are not to kill
furthermore vengeance is his on a
secular level I'm not going to say I'm
not going to ask anyone to carry out an
execution that he may one day come to
regret I'm not going to ask anyone to do
that we'll build more prisons sorry
best wishes for Ron DeSantis and his
administrative Reign well
actually what you brought up about
um the the death penalty and the fact
that someone has to actually carry it
out and the incredible psychological
burden of having to actually carry out
the executions
of all the arguments against the death
penalty I've always found that to be the
most compellent and that that's the one
that's that is raised the least often
you rarely hear him bring that up as an
argument against the death penalty the
fact that look an actual human being has
to do this and maybe that's just
something that we shouldn't ask anyone
to do
um
I do find that argument compelling
ultimately not persuasive though because
it's it's it is um more than balanced
out by the interests of justice and uh
and every and all the other reasons to
have the death penalty so
but still you know it's an interesting
thing to talk about what you said though
about uh the Lord has made his will
clear well you're right
but
um
but it goes the other way
that we know in in the Bible if you're
making the religious argument well we
know that in scripture particularly in
the Old Testament God prescribes the
death penalty
you know um which means now God
prescribes the death penalty and so that
that's in Scripture
um
does that mean that we should have the
death penalty for that every single
crime should lead to death no does that
mean that we can't have law laws that
that you know um determine when the
death penalty is used and when it isn't
obviously not but what it does mean is
that as Christians we are now precluded
from declaring that the death penalty is
some sort of inherent intrinsic evil
now you didn't use that phrase exactly
but that's basically the argument
basically the argument that's made by
many death penalty uh opponents
especially the ones that try to make a
religious argument against it
but you can't make that argument because
then you are accusing God of of
prescribing something that was
intrinsically immoral
which is which is heresy
so
yeah if you want to go
uh referring to scripture is a great
idea in general and on this issue if you
do that and you look at what scripture
actually says of the death penalty it's
very hard it's very difficult to read
the Bible Old and New Testament and Come
Away with the conclusion that the Bible
is a um is a you know a death penalty
abolitionist text
very clearly not want to pay attention
because this is your last chance to
celebrate President's Day this year you
can take advantage before it's too late
with the daily wires our presidents for
sale sale with a 40 off memberships the
big guy got 10 we are giving you 40 you
get access to the world of daily wire
plus with Fearless documentaries
gripping movies Prager use uh Dennis
prager's rather the Masters program and
the entire library of Jordan Peterson's
work including new productions like
Exodus logos and literacy and on
marriage all available to watch right
now coming down the pipeline to a TV or
laptop near you there are new episodes
of Ben Shapiro's the search Exodus part
two and then our much anticipated DW
kids content all of that and so much
more is on the way we're also giving you
up to 40 off select items in the daily
wire shop last chance to take advantage
of our presidents for sale sale today is
your last chance you got to do it you
got to go to dailywire.com subscribe to
become a member today that's
dailywire.com subscribe now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
last week I posted a very important poll
to Twitter the question who is the worst
wife in America there were four options
Jill Biden Meghan Markle Jada Pinkett
Smith and Gisele fetterman the wife of
Senator John Federman now it proved to
be a close contest though one clear
winner emerged at the end Jada Pinkett
Smith GI Jane as Chris Rock would call
her who has uh escorted her husband Will
Smith through one public humiliation
ritual after another won the race with
32 percent of the vote close behind her
was Meghan Markle assuming her preferred
position by riding someone else's
coattails with 30 and then first lady
and notorious Elder abuser Jill Biden
with 22 percent followed finally by
Gisele fetterman with only 14 percent of
the vote
but after the events of this past week I
must now call for Mike Pence to do the
right thing and throw out these results
we need a new election and I think
Gisele fetterman deserves to win this
time
now Gisele earned the title before this
past week she earned it ever since her
husband nearly died from a stroke during
a political campaign and she rather than
insisting that he leave the race and
save his health in the process instead
help to shuffle him along from one
campaign stop to the next where he
humiliated himself with increasing
regularity only to eventually win the
senate seat because the Republicans
managed to run someone who was less
appealing to voters than an actual
vegetable somehow fetterman would um
end up in the hospital almost
immediately after being sworn in and
then again immediately after that he was
admitted over a week ago for his second
stint and is still there reportedly to
receive treatment for depression now I
must say reportedly because there's no
reason to believe any of the details
were given about fetterman's health at
this point all we can say for sure is
that the man is not well
that didn't stop Giselle his loving wife
from going on vacation anyway the daily
wire here's the report Senator John
fetterman's wife was slammed on social
media Friday after she revealed that her
first the first thing she did after her
husband was hospitalized with severe
depression was flee the country to go on
vacation fetterman checked himself into
a hospital last week for a multi-week
inpatient treatment regiment after the
attending physician in the United States
Congress recommended that he do so
Gisele fetterman who lived illegally in
the U.S for more than a decade said that
she took the family to Canada for a
vacation after leaving her husband in
the hospital NBC news reporter Dasha
Burns said last week that senior aides
the fettermen have indicated that it's
been difficult to distinguish the stroke
from from the depression saying it's
hard to tell at times if fetterman is
not hearing you or he is he is sort of
crippled by his depression and Social
Anxiety
quote a senior aide tells me both the
staff and fetterman himself were taken
by surprise by the severe onset of
depression the aid also says that this
hasn't compromised his ability to do the
job going forward and he'll be back to
work once he was once he's taken care of
his mental health
um so wait
just side note you can't tell if he
hears you when you speak to him
but that hasn't compromised his ability
to do the job of a senator
which actually might be true but what
does that tell you about the job of a
senator as for the details of Gisele's
impromptu Excursion out of the country
while her husband languished in the
hospital she tweeted this quote
I'm not really sure how to navigate this
journey but I'm figuring it out slowly
one week ago today when the news dropped
the kids were off from school and the
media trucks circled our home I did the
first thing I could think of pack them
up and in the car and drive we drove
straight into Canada we talked Lots
about hard things and how we all have to
face hard things about the need to be
gentle with ourselves and with all we
did some scary things but we did them
together we ziplined over Niagara Falls
and August got stuck we talked about
flexibility and the need to always have
an open heart and an open mind we also
talked about how joy and fun can and
must still exist even when someone we
love is in pain and tomorrow who knows
we'll try to do it all over again
now she also uh provides some pictures
and videos from their jaunt to Niagara
Falls
it should go without saying that
a good and attentive wife does not leave
the country on vacation while her
husband is experiencing a catastrophic
medical emergency
now we don't know whether John fetterman
is even fully conscious right now but if
he is I can only imagine what it must
have felt like when he called his wife
from his hospital bed expecting that she
would sound distraught only to hear
laughter and commotion in the background
like what's that honey oh we're uh we're
going ziplining in Canada it's so fun
wish you could be here anyway gotta go
of course it's it's not that a man in
the hospital wants his wife to be
miserable but he does want her empathy
he wants her concern her support
all of which seems to be lacking in
giselle's Behavior
of course some people have tried to
defend Gisele by insisting that while
she was only trying to get away from the
media Spotlight it was something that
she did to protect her kids they claim
that doesn't make any sense given that
Giselle has ruthlessly pursued the media
Spotlight and she was willing to
sacrifice her husband's Health to get it
you can't push your barely cognizant
husband over the finish line and into
the Senate and then five seconds later
claimed that you wish to Shield your
family from public scrutiny
that would have been easily achieved if
fetterman dropped out of the race after
he had his first stroke during the
primers remember that first stroke was
during the primaries
he could have easily just dropped out
and another Democrat would have been uh
would have been would have been the
nominee and probably would have won the
Senate
but now that he's a senator
you know now that you've made that
decision to push him over the Finish
Line his health is a matter of national
interest and importance
that's what she wanted and now she has
it
but even if we could justify the Niagara
Falls Tour on the basis that she was
trying to avoid the news cameras take
her kids Minds off of everything in the
process that wouldn't explain why she
needed to publish a string of tweets
about the experience complete with
pictures and video
Giselle seems to have gone to the Meghan
Markle School of protecting one's
privacy and even more to the point it
would not explain or Justify what she
says in the tweets and what she doesn't
say you'll notice that her husband's
name isn't mentioned she never expresses
any concern about him
instead she talks about herself her
journey her need for joy and fun
she has turned her husband's medical
crisis into a personal journey of
self-discovery
and in that way and in several other
ways she is you know the quintessential
modern liberal woman and I don't mean
that as a compliment
it's actually appropriate that on the
same day that Gisele published her tweet
Thread about her fun vacation another
tweet written by a different but equally
vapid liberal woman went viral this time
it was um
Dr Nicole lepera is a psychologist and
an expert in quote unquote self-healing
lepera has amassed an enormous online
following with gems like the one she
posted on Friday which says this quote
putting everyone else's needs before
your own isn't selfless it's
self-abandonment Society glorifies this
and it's a massive reason why so many of
us are unwell
yes that's the problem with society that
it encourages people to be selfless
the solution to our cultural problem
therefore says the psychologist is to
put greater emphasis on selfishness
because that's the ingredient we're
missing obviously surely we've all
noticed this I mean when you when you
look around at Society the first thing
you think is wow there really isn't
enough selfishness out there
now this is totally backwards of course
it may be theoretically possible to go
too far in putting other people's needs
in front of your own
theoretically that's possible Maybe
but that is not the direction that our
culture pushes people
and if you're having trouble in your
relationships it is almost certainly not
because you are too outwardly focused
too worried about helping others uh too
selfless
that may be the story that you tell
yourself
well the story is almost always fiction
and it is a fiction grounded in your
selfishness
Giselle fetterman is a prime example of
this phenomenon
and a very public example
because that's what she wanted to be
and that is why she is today finally
canceled that'll do it for this portion
shows move over to the members block if
you're not a member yet you can become a
member and use code wall should check
out for two months free on all annual
plans
hope to see you over there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]